[Music]
so today we're gonna have an
introduction to Big Data so can you put
your hands up in the audience and I'm
gonna do my best to have a look if
you're working with big data at the
moment okay so that's about a third of
the room and I'm blind there we go
right you have an impression so a little
story about Big Data to start with and
you've probably all know Google Street
or Street View so when we were having
these cars driving around taking
pictures so we could have this nice
there's a great story about how Street
View actually started I saved that for
another day but if you google it and
Google Larry and Street View and how it
all started I'm sure you'll find a nice
story and when we were doing that we
were just basically trying to capture
those images so we could create this
nice experience what we didn't really
think about at the time was how much
data we were actually capturing so I
think I'm gonna move on to the next
slide and here we're going to look at
what kind of information is already in
that image and obviously in the years
after Street View when we starts to
supply information on which way we're
routing your traffic and things like
that which signs where the addresses are
what's going on so there's all this
information there so this is quite a
rich data set and you could imagine that
if you have this data you can already
start to do something very useful with
it if you can somehow get to the
information is stored in there so that's
a little story to start with so big data
applications and some of them involve a
human and others don't
okay what does that mean so let's think
about an application that involves a
human for example if you're running some
kind of experiment and you're trying to
see what users are actually doing so you
say well you know if we give this
feature do we actually get some response
from that is it proving to be successful
and so you're actually looking at their
interaction others might not necessarily
involve a human attraction might be for
example blocking for turrets a
fraudulent there we go fraudulent
transactions so for example we're
looking at traffic credit cards coming
in transactions and we want to know
which ones are actually you know valid
or fraudulent
so we might build a model or something
let you start processes in that data you
can imagine how much data you might have
you have coming at you as a bank with
all these credit card transactions going
on all the time so there's a couple of
examples of big data applications or
let's say use cases and now we're going
to look today we're gonna actually look
at four different tools that we can use
from the big from Google Cloud yeah
sweets which will actually help us do
something with big data so we can look
at how we analyze data we're going to
look at how we can prepare data we're
gonna look at how we can process it
we're actually going to look at some of
the end results how we can actually
start using that in dashboarding for
example and also how we might actually
leverage the skills of a data scientist
to actually interact with that data to
create a for example machine learning
model so this is a little something to
think about about Big Data as well
because when you talk to people are
victims so well you know I'm not I don't
have I'm not doing anything with big
data you know I am have a databases a
terabyte of information in there it's
not a lot but then let's have a think
like what what kind of data do you have
actually at the moment so there's a data
that you analyze now today and that data
is probably like I said in a database it
might be able to terror by or something
like that and you it's well structured
you know quite well you your business
intelligence teams are probably working
with it quite a lot so you got a good
grip on what that actually is there
could be data that you collect but you
don't actually process or analyze so you
could be collecting logs from your
website application for example server
logs which telling you what things are
happening what you what users are
clicking on what page users start off on
and where they move to throughout that
journey on the website but you might not
be processing that for example and then
there's data that you're not even
collecting so maybe in those logs you're
only collecting that a certain level and
you're not actually keeping all of the
information because it's too expensive
to store or something and then also on
top of that there's this data you can
actually acquire from third parties so
what would it be a good case in this so
let's say you're doing something with
recommendations and you want to get some
information about seasonality you know
what's happening with the weather is
there a correlation there you're
probably not going to go and stick
census up all around the world someone
else is doing that for you
so you probably buy that data will find
some way of acquiring it so you can
bring it in your ecosystems to start
doing the same so it's quite as going
back to that first image when we took
those photos there's really a lot of
information there once you find out the
use cases and start looking at what data
could be there and how you could
discover that then you can think more
about what you might actually want to do
with that data so we're going to start
off with some of the challenges and the
first one is hard to develop big data
pipelines so we're going to talk about a
UI application that we've created called
Google Cloud Data prep this is a it was
launched this year and it's a tool that
basically allows your analysts and data
scientists to actually interact with raw
data to clean it up to process it and
actually to get it into a database where
they can start analyzing it so one of
the challenges and before I joined
Google I was I headed up a business
intelligence team for a number of years
and one of the challenges that the team
would have especially the analysts on
the team was when we didn't have enough
development capacity to build pipelines
some of the analysts and some of the
data scientists they wanted to start you
know experimenting creating models and
coming up with some some information to
tell you know their their business users
what was going on with the products and
that kind of stuff but because we hadn't
processed that data they didn't really
yeah they won't be able to make those
insights so having some kind of tool
where they can kind of self-service
where they can actually go in there and
process they look at that data process
it and key to this is that once they've
actually you know how to look at that
data and played around with the sample
there whatever we create there that we
can actually apply a scale and use it to
pros to process all that data that we
that they might want to use in the data
warehouse for their next step so the
analysis or the data science so we're
going to look at two data sets one the
the dates at the bottom is ad
impressions and this is basically some
data stored in the CSV file and as the
red highlights is highlighting we're
actually we want to extract some
information there which is the product
ID so that there's something you might
see on a web URL you know someone goes
to a page and the product ID is there
but we need to get a that ID
the other thing that we want to do is we
want to look at some transactions and
these transactions restoring a big query
and if you're interested in bigquery I
probably say this again somewhere later
in the talk but if you're interested in
bigquery stick around for the next talk
because Israel is going to give us a
great talk about bigquery so we were
only be touching on that very lightly
during this talk but if in bigquery in
this particular dataset we have some
transactions and what's actually quite
special about these transactions is that
we're storing actually in bigquery
ourself nested data so one of the things
you can do at bigquery is not to store
you know your flat table but you can
actually have within each row a
collection so think about order and
order lines or a transaction and
transaction lines so we have a
transaction with the different lines
with the transaction lines and we want
to get to all that the transaction line
level we're storing the product key and
that's what we want to get so what we're
basically going to try and do in this
data set we're going to try to join the
two together and we want to create one
dataset where we can look at the which
or which ad impressions actually
resulted in a transaction and maybe we
want to look at the time between those
two or something so we're going to
attempt to do this now in a demo without
actually writing any code so that's the
the goal of data prep so I'm gonna
switch over to a demo this is cloud date
prep it's accessible via the cloud
console and we're going to start off
I've imported to date sets to save time
the top one is the CSV and this other
dataset here the scale 2 is our data set
from bigquery so we're going to go to a
flows here and here is where you
basically create a new flow so once
you've imported those data sets here's
when you're going to start working with
them so we're going to create a new flow
demo please be kind ok we're going to
add a couple of data sets here so I'm
adding the CSV and I'm adding the sales
scaled data set
okay so here's the salesgirl that's
coming from bigquery and here's the CSV
and you can already see here I dropped
the CSV that some action has already
occurred so basically what data prep is
doing is creating recipes and those
recipes is basically what you need to do
to cook your data from raw to something
well-cooked that you can start using so
let's have a look what it's already
suggested well it was a CSV so it
understood that it was a CSV so I looked
at the delimiter so there's a certain
amount of intelligence and and machine
learning behind this to actually do some
of this stuff and you'll see in a moment
how powerful some of that can be but
it's already come up with suggestion you
can see here on the right so it's
actually worked out the the type of
columns that it is let's go and have it
edit our recipe for a moment keeping an
eye on the time in the meantime
there we go so what do we see here we've
basically got all of the columns
extracted for us you can see for each
column it's already suggested a data
type so this one is alphanumeric this
one is a number and here we have a date
time and we've got the distribution of
the data so basically the data set were
imported was a CSV in a cloud storage
bucket if there'd been multiple a CSV is
there it would basically be able to
import all of those and you see at the
top here if this is quite a small data
set so it's just picking the whole data
set because that fits quite nicely but
if it wasn't you could actually if
there's a bigger data set we could
collect a random sample so you use
different sampling techniques to
actually have a look at that data but
since we have all of it here yeah that's
easy enough so we can see here the
distribution of the data and score look
at the different columns and one of the
columns here the event time if I look
here I can see that there are there are
some there's some data which is actually
a little bit problematic what is it
saying let's have a look so you notice
all I did was click here on that data so
I just clicked on that little red mark
so data prep is really the kind of GUI
where you have to just click around and
and it kind of works out what you're
doing so I clicked here on this red part
because that looked odd to me
and it came up with a suggestion there
were several suggestions one of them is
that so let's have a look at this one
this one here is saying I'm going to
delete the rows so delete where it where
it doesn't conform to a timestamp so
there was a text in there timed out
something like that but actually it's
it's coming up here and say well the
rest of the dates conformed to this
pattern so let's use this pattern and
you can go ahead here and edit that if
you want but I'm quite happy with this
so I'm gonna add it to the recipe and
over here on the right you can see the
little open recipe and you see already
those those steps they are needed to do
to go from the CSV file into the columns
and and this new step you just added to
delete the rows you can see that they're
all here so break the rows using
new line is a delimiter and we're going
to split into columns on comma we're
going to convert the first row two
headers and then we're going to delete
all the rows where it doesn't match our
date/time timestamp so we have those but
I said we wanted to look at the URL and
we wanted specifically we want to get
that product ID out there so if we look
here here's that product ID so what I'm
going to do is I said you have to kind
of click and show it what you want to do
so I didn't quite get all of the
information there so something I'm not
really good with a mouse on there there
we go
so I've selected that and it's come up
with some suggestions what's it saying
here it's saying do I want to replace
PID equals one one for blah with empty
string that's not really useful no I
mean it will work for the no I'm not
extracting anything so let's try
something else let's try to select
another one at the same time so I select
another one and now it's come up with a
pattern that it's asking me if I want to
apply this pattern if I just look you on
the right you can already see it's doing
a good job of actually extracting that
product ID so let's have a little look
what's going on and you can see here is
looking for a pattern but obviously the
PID equals isn't part of my pattern so
I'm just going to take that part out
there we go put that down here so I'm
going to say it starts after the product
ID and now you can see in my new column
I have quite a nice product ID so I can
add that to the recipe and the only
other thing I'm going to do here is I'm
going to rename this column to PID that
was the force touch on my Mac if anyone
uses Mac don't all laugh at once okay so
I've got my product IDs now let's go
back and have a look at the other
dataset so here I have the the sales
scaled and to see what we can do with
this so let's add a new recipe and now
we're going to go in and edit that
right so it hasn't done anything yet but
what you can see here on the sales order
lines is I basically got an array and I
want to do something with this array so
I'm gonna select the whole column there
we go and it's gonna give me some
options it's gonna say here do I want to
delete this column do I want to split it
into 170 different columns nope and here
it has do I want to convert these arrays
into rows that looks quite good so now
I've gone up in like a kind of order of
magnitude here so I'm now at 35,000 rows
so I think I'll keep that as the first
step but now obviously I want to get to
this data and star acting it so let's
click on this one let's see what's going
to suggest so it's going to give me some
options one of the options here is to
split let's have a look what happens
there that doesn't look very good should
have some more and now I just clicked
back
alright that move me this is the demo
effect
so I'm quickly going to do that game
okay it already done that for me so I
need to find something here that's gonna
actually understand these columns
properly here so I already had the right
one selected and I've just done that
game my excuses third time lucky and I
promised I would disable the
three-finger swipe on my Mac one day
which is actually a promise I made after
my last demo but still got around to it
I have another demo next week so if
anyone is in the audience knows me
personally wants to give me a prod that
would be much appreciated right here we
go using one finger so it's already
splitting those columns for me and one
other thing I'm not going to keep all of
them now I just want to keep a couple of
them so I want to keep the product key
that's actually all I want to keep so
I'm just gonna delete the rest of these
there we go
and I'm gonna add that's the recipe just
gonna take a few seconds
right so you see now I've extracted that
product key so what I've done I took
that array of data we've broke that
array into rows we are nested it
effectively and we've now extracted the
product key column which is what we were
looking for so the next thing I want to
do is join this data with the previous
data set so they come down here and I
say join and it's going to ask me which
data set do I want to join it with and
obviously it's my ABC one why am I not
seeing that this flow so there we go
that one so I want to join it with that
one previous selected data set
okay and the first thing I'm gonna do
here is look at the join keys so to join
keys right it suggested to join but it's
not very good it's not very good so
let's actually go and look at that and
maybe change that around of it so let's
edit that we don't want to join on the
sales order key we want to join on the
product key and we we were also looking
at customers so let's also join with the
customer key yes that's good and now
give me one more and in this one I want
to join the customer key with the user
ID and I'm going to save that and now I
can look at which columns I want so
obviously I don't want all of these
columns here because you know it have
the user ID and I'll keep the product
key I'll keep the customer key I'll take
the order date in the event time and
let's just take the total sales and then
we can add that to recipe
so I've now joined this two datasets
together and apart from you know going
back and forth between my screens
because my sticky fingers we've actually
managed to join two datasets we've done
some quite complicated translation
transformations we've extracted product
IDs with unless today - all that's left
for me to do now is to run this pipeline
so I run this earlier because it will
actually take a few minutes to run so
let's have a look at what that looked
like
let's go back - so here's the material
next demo you can see the same pipeline
and if you look at jobs here you can see
that I actually ran this yesterday that
was the pipeline clip on there on the
job ID we can have a look at the recipe
because the exporter there we go so it
will give me an overview of what I've
done and so basically what's going to
happen when you run this job it's going
to create a dataflow pipeline and we
look at data flow in a moment and that
pipeline will get executed in Google
Cloud so it can really scale to whatever
size it needs to to deal with however
much information is coming on it and at
the end we can actually send that data
to bigquery or back to a cloud storage
for example having in bigquery be super
handy because then we could actually do
some analytics and some dashboarding
from it but I hope this is already
giving a good idea about actually what
you might be able to achieve with data
prep I'm just through actually looking
at data trying to understand them and at
the end we're going to create a pipeline
and that pipeline you can actually then
run and then run it again so you can
actually have your data appended each
subsequent time so this should give you
a good indication of what you can do
with cloud data prep so we're going to
move on we're going to look at that
particular job that we were looking at
was actually about a batch job no we had
the data it was fixed
we had a CSV that was ready for us all
the data was really available for us in
bigquery from the the transactions and
now we're going to look at how can we
actually handle some data that's coming
in as a stream and again we're going to
be using data flow for this so I
mentioned dates flow a few times in that
last presentation
will you that will data prep itself will
actually create a data flow job which is
going to run to process your data so
what is data flow and we're going to
take a use case of streaming so a few
things about streaming a lot of the good
systems are out there were built to you
know they were designed to run on
distributed systems they weren't
necessarily designed to be very friendly
for developers I mean MapReduce is great
and Google we published a white paper
back of MapReduce somewhere early 2000
it's a fundamental part of a lot of the
products that we're going oh that we
make at Google also data flow is also
behind bigquery a certain level so it's
a very important and let's say
programming model but it's quite
difficult for as a developer especially
when you're working on small tart or for
the first time so get your head around
and then we have some additional
problems we have batch which we just
looked at which is really nice when
everything is already there and you can
actually take it move on and and you
know the whole data set that you're
looking at is complete so nothing's
going to come at you later you know you
look at data that arrives tomorrow and
because it's a batch it's a complete set
so you know it you're looking at the
whole picture
in in the case of streaming that's not I
mean you're just getting single events
or let's say little groups of events
that are coming at you and you don't
actually know if you've seen everything
you don't even know if everything's in
the right order so this is whole notion
of processing time and event time that
can be quite difficult to wrap your
heads around so the first key component
in this and I've actually should have
put a architects light in here
the first key component is actually
getting those events in so one of the
things that we're going to use is pops
up pops up is basically a message
queueing it's a global system you can
send literally millions of messages per
second so the system if you need to it
will guarantee you at least once
delivery on any subscriber so it's
called pops ups or publish and subscribe
so have a publisher and you have a topic
so you publish your sending saying to a
given topic and all your subscribers on
that topic you can have as many as you
want as well will sit there and listen
and they will receive messages either by
a push or a pull making
and this is like think of you're going
to create any pipeline downstream where
you actually gonna be handling streaming
data pops up is a good place to actually
start buffering that because you know if
you turn that system off for it's not
running you still need to be able to get
at the data here so or when you want to
start up again you want to be able to
pick off where that with the data that
you haven't yet processed so having a
buffer in between is very important and
a little bit about the event and
processing time so in an ideal world we
would see that diagonal line there that
diagonal slope that would be perfect you
know every time something happens we can
process it instantly in reality this is
not the case I'll give you an example
now so in this example before I explain
what Apache beam is in this example here
we have event a time on the x-axis and
the y-axis we're processing time and
again we have the the dotted line that
diagonal line which is the perfect line
so the number three is almost on the
perfect line imagine these numbers
represent scores on a game and the only
thing that we're actually interested in
doing is for this particular user and
let's just say all this data is from one
user we are interested in actually
calculating his score and sending it
back to him so or putting out on a
leaderboard somewhere so every time we
get an update with how many points he
scored so we want to be able to process
that and you know represent
near-real-time on a dashboard his score
so three is really nice the event time
in a person time very close to each
other this doesn't really happen very
often so what we do what we do with data
flow is we try to create a heuristic
watermark which represents this kind of
relationship between the proto between
the event time and the processing time
but it's based on the information they
receives and it's not going to be based
on things like if something comes much
later than I expected so score nine here
came really late you know it happened
just a little bit after 12:01 and we
didn't process it until 1208 so it came
really late in fact many different
scores that we received all the way up
to this score here in the meantime we
actually processed those before we even
saw this one come in so that's
problematic what we've done here so
Apache beam is the open source project
for dataflow dataflow is our managed
is to run Apache beam so much like
tensorflow is an open-source project for
machine learning and you can use cloud
ml to run your machine learning projects
do your training or to do your
predictions their data flow will give
you the same ability to take your Apache
beam processing so it's a MapReduce like
but the important thing about Apache
beam is unified batch and stream and
what does unified batching streaming is
in basically we're giving it a semantics
to be able to deal with data regardless
whether this batch will stream so you
don't need to go and create two
different pipelines and then the
important part being able to do that is
to be able to first of all window your
data so you want to window in fixed
windows in session time do you want to
window in sliding windows for example
and also to be able to deal with data as
it arrives late or early and in this
particular case here of nine we're
dealing with a piece of data that
arrives late so that data comes in late
we fire a trigger and say it's coming
late and in that programming order as
well we also tell it in our window if
data comes out as late we would also
like to still be able to get we keep all
the data we have in the window so we can
accumulate and then we will add that and
we will emit an update of the score so
you don't have to do it like that but
that's just an example of how you might
want to do it so let's move on so if
anyone that's visited the booth from the
incident insights this might already be
familiar to you this is the architecture
I was speaking about that at the
beginning so pops up we've got events
happening here taxis are driving around
and we're going to use data flow to
process that information and as that
information first we're gonna drift
through things so all the solid arrows
here are actually streaming lines and
all the dashed arrows these are batch
lines so there are three things going on
in this pipeline the first one is we're
taking all the data that comes at us all
the events that we receive and we're
sending them straight to bigquery so we
can analyze them by doing that all the
data that we already have in bigquery so
our data warehouse all the data that we
already have therefore this particular
table and all the data that's being
streamed in we can query so we have a
the possibilities to do real-time
querying on the data and historical data
as it comes in and that's good because
then we can use something like data prep
to analyze the data we look at some
other stuff in a moment and once
than that we could use that data for
example to retrain our model and here we
would train a model with intensive flow
in the cloud ml the service I just
mentioned and once that models ready and
been trained we could actually and we
could release a new version to our
serving part of the cardinal space and
you can have different versions there
which'll a enables you to do like a bee
testing or models and what we're going
to do in this particular example is
we're going to make a prediction on how
likely the users in that taxi so what
information do we have we have the where
the trip started where the trip ended
how long the trip is taking so far and
the number of people that are in the in
the in the taxi itself and we'll make
the predictions on that or on how likely
they are to respond to a given advert so
one of those adverts might be and you
can see at the example if you want to
see more of this at the booth but one of
this example might be three people
driving in a taxi to the airport might
be interested in having you know sushi
before you fly not taking responsibility
for the for the adverts another example
might be someone driving from the
airport into town as a single person and
they might want to say well would you
like to visit this wine bar because we
know this wine bar is you know very
popular with single people that just
come into town for example so that's the
second leg of this pipeline now we have
this information still coming in here so
we've sent some of that we've sent a
copy of that information to the data
warehouse and we're sending another copy
of that information well we're calling
the data here to make a prediction and
once we've made that prediction we will
send them like the recommendations for
the adverts and the last thing that
we're doing is we're sending a small
aggregate of that data so we're
aggregating that data comes in so we can
produce a heat map so think about like a
dashboard that you might have at the
control center to kind of show what's
going on at the moment so how many taxis
are driving around at the moment which
locations are they driving around it you
know if you're having a conversation
with a potential client you can say well
look this area's really popular with
taxis you would you like to have me like
it could be your way of actually trying
to promote your advertising space in
there so these adverts will be obviously
displayed on a little screen in the back
of the taxi as they were driving around
so very modern taxi
okay so I'm gonna just show your data
flow very briefly because I've got a
speed up a little bit it's not like me
to talk over time so this is the same
pipeline so I just show you a few
features here one this is the dates are
coming from pops up it's being read from
pops up and we're sending it to bigquery
and you can see this is running at the
moment so again go to the demo Biff if
you want to get more details on this and
the other branch I want to show you here
is the ml call and one of the useful
things that you might want to do here is
just open up the logs and I've just
selected the ml call I'll just give it a
second for us to populate and you can
see here that there are there are
requests being made and their responses
being given for the different
predictions so this is online it's
running at the moment and please have a
look
so that was data flow so we just looked
at a bit hard to develop dates pipelines
a good thing too just to reinforce
everything that we've looked at at the
moment is completely managed there are
no computers for you to manage yourself
if you run something in data flow and
you put the right configuration like you
know you use as many machines as you
need to it will scale up and scale down
to do whatever it needs to do to get the
job done and the same with bigquery data
prep is creating a data flow pipeline in
the background and pub/sub is a
completely managed service and you're
just not concerned by any number of
machines or anything there is just the
throughput that you want so this last
but this next part is about hard to
scale and operate on big data
applications so let's have a look at
some of the challenges these are some of
the challenges I'm not going to read
them all out but basically this is where
you want to be you want to spend your
time on insights and analytics you don't
want to spend your time on doing
performance tuning resource provisioning
all that stuff so let's move on let's
look at those free applications again I
just basically foretold this slide but
pops up for ingestion data flow for
processing and for analysis bigquery
again no sharding no capacity guessing
no idle resources etc this is these are
managed services
and in that keep so bigquery is using
standard sequel notation so you don't
have to go and learn a new sequel
dialect there are a few add-ons for
unnecessarily we talked about in the
next conversation I can show just that
very very briefly here so here is a row
in the table and here are the the nested
rows let's say the repeated rows so we
have a few extensions to deal with that
and data flow that all-important
processing part because this is where
the magic is happening where you're
actually transforming your data and
filtering and playing all sorts of
complicates off this is where your
business logic is you can write that in
a patchy beam that's open source you can
run that on SPARC you can run it on
flink on your own how dupa clusters is
running at the moment or if you run it
by us we're running in a managed service
and you won't have to worry about all
those things on the right this line here
is basically showing a little bit about
how how much Google has been involved in
open source and Big Data technology so
think like GFS and MapReduce these are
two white papers from I said early 2000
there you go 2004 and these were
basically white papers that were really
kind of instigated the whole Hadoop yeah
conversation let's say Dremel are
externalized version of Dremel is
bigquery basically we built bigquery
because MapReduce wasn't fast enough
nor was it friendly enough so one of
those things we want to spend time on
insights we don't want to spend time
writing complicated pipelines if we
don't have to so with bigquery you're
just using standard sequel and you can
run literally a petabyte query in a
couple of minutes it's going to be an
expensive query because there's a lot of
data to process but if you want to run a
petabyte in a couple of minutes it's
completely possible with bigquery so
another challenge is silos and analytics
silos of analytics there we go so how
can we avoid those well we can avoid
those like we avoid most things by
separating out responsibilities in this
case separating storage and compute so
we have on the lower line here we have
storage options so cloud
storage object storage files we have
bigquery and bigquery in this case when
we're talking about bigquery storage so
bigquery has two parts the processing
and the storage and bigquery storage is
really optimized storages is column it's
column up to my storage so you can
really get great performance from your
queries and the last one here is cloud
BigTable this is the this is our own
internal version of what external
version for example in Hadoop community
you would see something like HBase if
you big big big table itself is an open
source but we do supply an API which is
HBase compliant so if you would like to
move from a big table into HBase to
running your own HBase cluster in the
future you could do that completely and
we have an API which means that how you
communicate with BigTable would be the
same how you communicate with HBase so
this is storage options on the top line
where the processing so we just looked
at dataflow bigquery analytics so this
is basically the part of the bigquery
were you actually writing queries and
processing your data and data proc they
don't have time to speak to about data
proc today but data proc is basically
our spark and Hadoop the Google Cloud
way you can spin up a cluster in under
90 seconds you can basically start
thinking of MapReduce and spark jobs and
hive jobs or Pig scripts in the terms of
a job as opposed to a cluster you're
built by the minute because we can spin
up and tear down so quickly it
completely changes how you look at that
so if you're if you're if you're running
Hadoop let's go and you're interested to
know more about this please contact any
of us and we'd be happy to or any of our
partners would be happy to talk you
through that in all three of these cases
here what we're basically doing we're
given the options to be able to interact
with any of these processing units with
any of the storage units underneath as
you can see so that really gives you the
ability to kind of separate where you're
storing things and make it available for
all your different processing
environments cloud and Mail engine I
said this is our managed service for
running tensorflow I I'm just going to
leave that there that's kind of a
bit vague isn't it but what we're
basically trying to say here is that
what we're doing on the data processing
site we're doing on the machine learning
site as well we're tend to flow so if
you think in this in this discussion
intense flows taking the same spot as
Apache being open source project you can
run the way you want if you want to run
them by us we'll make sure good security
good performance good cost then we have
a managed service to actually help you
do that and now we're gonna look at some
of the data science tools that you might
need so the first one going to look at
is data lab quick hands up again if
you've used to Jupiter notebook or
Zeppelin or ipython so great that's a
fair number of hands so for those of you
that don't know it a Jupiter notebook is
basically a way in which an analyst or a
data scientist might want to write his
code in Python or are to actually you
know start processing data and whether
that's actually doing some analysis or
it's creating a machine learning model
it's a really interactive and
collaborative way of working I was
showing we have a managed option which
is called data lab and the nice thing
about data it's based on ipython
notebooks as well and it basically it
brings all of the connections that you
need all the Google products to one
space and it has some more collaboration
options overlay in a second so the first
thing I need to do is let me just close
this I'll do it from scratch so if I go
to my VMs
you'll see I have a VM here running
called big data workshop I'm going to
use the cloud shell and I'm going to
connect to this VM in this way just a
few seconds there we go
so I'm gonna quote data lab and if you
didn't have a data lab instance like I
have here you could just do instead of
writing the next word connect you would
write create you can also give a machine
type if you wanna have a slightly bigger
machine sight worth noticing here the
machine type that I used was actually
it's actually too big so it's actually
given me a recommendation so all the
stuff that we tried to do outside of
Google Cloud to get off your ability we
tried to do inside Google Cloud as well
and obviously other Google products
so here's give me a recommendation based
on my usage that you know I could use a
cheaper machine and save some money so
that's good to know
but here I'm just going to connect so
data lab connect and I just need to type
the name now so big data workshop that
will sell for the SSH tunnel okay
and this little web preview here I could
select there and actually clicked on
page one I already have it running here
once I click and open I basically get my
data this is kind of the the menu page
and here is a notebook you see
connection failed because at the time it
wasn't connected if I just refresh this
now you'll see that it's all fine and
we're going to run very very quickly
through this notebook because I do want
to show you data studio as well and I've
got 4 minutes and 48 seconds left
please can I have five more so here's
the in basically nice thing about this
is that you can combine markup with
actual work that you're doing in
different cells there's first cells into
interesting I'm just importing something
but the second cell is really nice the
second cell here I'm going to actually
ask me to describe one of the tables in
bigquery and you see this two percent
aside the language I'm using here is
Python if you see this two percentage
signs that's basically telling data lab
this is a magic cell so if I use two
percentage lines the whole cell was
magic if I use one percentage sign then
it's just that line is magic so it's
basically say go use the
that's already done in the background
and that plumbing will allow me in this
case connect a big query without having
to write all that stuff because it's in
my project I have the right permissions
and it will describe the table for me
so there we go it describes the table
and I get a quite nice description about
all the different columns I have and
here's an example of some of the nested
data so here I have hits and under hits
I would have actually repeats of this
I'm going to go down and do a little bit
of query so I'm gonna go to the bottom
in interest of time I'm gonna run this
query and then basically what I've done
by running this query here I haven't
actually run it yeah I've just told it
to get ready and I basically say when I
call conversion to run this query so
here we're going to run the query and
I'm actually going to say now execute
and and and put them there yeah show me
the data and it's going to show me the
data but I would like to sing a little
bit more useful with this to make it a
little bit more visualized and I'm going
to use the same key so here I'm running
a sang key and this dataset that we're
looking at is conversion on analytics so
it's very similar to that first use case
it's like okay given that you start off
on this page on the website and you move
to we want you to be here so let's after
the shopping cart what's the conversion
for example and here we can see if we're
the Sankey if I start with the product
page you know so many are abandoned and
so many are completed so it gives me a
good visual representation if I start
from the home page you know the
proportion between abandoned and
completed is slightly different that
seems to be working slightly better but
more people actually landing on the
product page to the home page you can
draw your own conclusions but this is a
really good way of interacting one thing
to mention is that when you run data lab
it's already tied in to get so you have
Unger and a and a nun git will actually
allow you to connect to the git instance
which is running on your Google cloud
project or if you want you can connect
to a github instance and I can actually
use this to check in the work I do so if
I'm trying to share this with multiple
people they can all work on that you can
receive the latest updates and all of
that's out of the box so once you just
basically do that data lab create and
give it a name you can start working in
data lab use that machine and you know
people can work together to do to make
useful things and she
amongst each other so this is a good way
for a date scientist of an analyst right
to explore data or start writing the
model and the last one I'm going to show
so I'm actually almost on time is data
studio so when you run a query on us a
big query we charge you through the
query the size of the query and we
charge you for the storage we have a
product which is similar to other
dashboarding products out there it's a
little bit more simple but it has one
amazing feature it's in my personal
opinion well has two amazing features
first of all it's free so you can
actually use this and you can you give
it as many users as you need to they can
all work together on that and you're
only paying for the queries that are
running so here is an example of a
dashboard being created and the first
thing I'm going to show and show you
some View mode so this is what the
dashboard will look like if someone was
actually yeah looking at it you can
select the date here you can look at
what's going on here this is all kind of
standard dashboard stuff I will show you
very quickly one thing and that one
thing that I want to show you is
collaboration this is the part I
personally thinks amazing what we do at
Google with things like G suite so with
sheets and documents have you ever used
them the ability to work together at the
same time on a document we also have in
our dashboard in product so you can come
into this product and I've actually got
two screens running here so at the
moment this other user here you can see
that's not me that's Google Account
instant insights and here that's where
you can see a nice photo of me so that's
me obviously my name is Robert I
so this using here it doesn't have the
ability to edit it so I'm gonna change
the sharing rules let me have a quick
look so if I go to share the report I
can see here by advanced I've already
shared with other users but they
currently view it if I say that they can
edit it as well save the changes click
done you can see now if i refresh this
page that I can also edit come on there
we go so I can also edit on this page
and I'm out of time but one moment I'm
going to add an extra page to this
report I've just done that I'm going to
add a new chart let
take a bar chart where are you here and
add a bar chart for example it's already
gonna come up with a suggestion I'm
gonna try adding a game okay den my
effect right the end yeah well while
you're refreshing let's go to this user
maybe your okay so let's add a bar chart
there we go I added a bar chart it's
already giving me a suggestion obviously
you can go here and do all the kind of
stuff that you would normally with a bar
chart and you can see here in real time
that this user you can also start
working on that bar chart so the only
thing I'm going to do here is to say
style and I'm going to say make it
horizontal and if I go back it's
horizontal so there are two users
working together creating the same
dashboard and with that I'll let you
I'll let you get ready for your next
talk thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]